and lastly the Oscar if you do win an
Academy Award what does that mean to you
and if you don't uh well hi i have to
say like boonville sorry i am very
inspired of buddha well and when he was
nominated for oscar for the discreet
charm of the Borg wasps he said the
journalists were asking him do you think
you will get an Oscar and he's like he
said yeah you know my producer bought it
already and there was what and then he
actually won the Oscar and in his award
speech he said yeah you can say whatever
you want about Americans but they they
are true third to their word so I think
that was like an inspiring way of
thinking of it because I mean Oscars is
like the biggest thing when it comes to
movie all around the world and there are
so many expectations and it's so hard to
get nominated and yeah so I I have to
put some how to say I Ronnie into it
when I when I talk about it thank you
you